welcome to this video playing Allah
gasps my old nemesis hear me let's see
what we get typically we get some kind
of boring and game where he slightly
worse and Klingon until hell freezes
over and this is guy is really something
else he plays this all the time Oh on
let's see let's see me and to play this
plays endgame I have also played to play
more exciting openings against him but
somehow it doesn't it doesn't really
change things you still get those kind
of boring endgames castles you will take
this should be a taken care off okay
castles naughty 44 Queen deform so let's
see um jump like you should should be
about equal here whoopsie to yeah he's
got this actor hook still could be one
yeah it's not not really much of a
difference I know I'm playing right into
into his strength theaters kind of
boring in games but though I always
think that I should try to improve with
this kind of situation and therefore not
necessarily avoided yeah we will trade a
against deep on I forgot about Rocky III
which are actually intended but okay
it's not not a big deal
hmm let's let's briefly think about this
you will play b6 problem
yeah it's not not really mentoring much
look a for the mk4 mm-hmm stupid it's a
slightly stupid what I played okay could
have played better at least
yeah well if five is not not really a
problem i can i can really take because
of my better King position I don't think
that is outside passer is a problem
yeah I need to I need to be quick little
playbook against uconn time we've seen
this more than once on this channel so i
must be a bit quicker
I'm not sure
not sure this is still a slight problem
this pawn
you always need to watch the clock so
that I don't fall so far behind
yeah this is this is really completely
drawn but of course it will continue
that's so i can i can do back i can do
basically anything i only need to do it
do it quickly yeah this is also also
possible just advancing trading points
the funny thing is he plays every
position on time like rook against rook
and so on but if he's down on time he's
banging for drawers this is really cute
check check it's still a drawl of course
sorry yeah check and really not not much
to try
check yeah I have no way to to play for
win William check check Grom Arthur on
it's a repetition I was I wanted to
offer a draw but it's it's a repetition
yeah again not the most exciting game
but it's always tense against him John
yeah I met amid amid some some mistake
here because right here I actually
wanted to play beforehand I wanted to
play the rook back here maybe this is
better our a form LOL so maybe maybe not
not extracting the the optimum here
that's the c-4 ID as well yeah maybe I
played at it too quickly here too yeah
not for too much behind all the clock
all right tenzen game thanks for
watching